[Applaudissements]
regardez là quand les deux copines se
retrouvent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça fait plaisir une équipe soudée des
gens l'idée de la mort part 2 81 peine
que vous allez vous faire une
déclaration d'amour à aux trucages et
sera réalisé sans trucage question oui
tout de suite l'argent
bonjour je me prénomme juliette la
semaine dernière j'ai été très choquée
car lors d'une de nos émissions je veux
un des chroniqueurs prendre la parole
est ce normal car je pensais qu'ils
étaient là uniquement pour leur physique
[Rires]
non mais je comprends votre surprise
juliette mais contrairement aux idées
reçues les chroniqueurs ont bien droit
de parler pendant l'émission
si parfois nous ne le faisons pas c'est
juste parce que nous sommes très
nombreux autour de la table et aussi
parce que la syrie nous ne travaillons
pas assez à part gilles uns les autres
c'est que des grosses feignasses
enfin c'est ce qui nous est dit la
semaine dernière pour nous motiver face
à un tel encouragement dans la prise
d'antenne deux attitudes possibles
l'abattement et le mutisme ou la volonté
de prendre la parole comme isabelle
morini bosc qui ce jour là était très
motivé pour donner tort à cyril
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors aussi demandé sur sa page facebook
si quelqu'un dit d'arrêter mon avocat
spécialisé dans le droit à l'image et au
tableau c'est une création c'est vous
qui avaient tous pensé qu'ils avaient
tous fait vous êtes partis d'une feuille
blanche et rien que pour ça bravo
mélissa et car il faut que vous jouiez
avec notre preview et 7 5
c'est un truc de ouf à l'aise je dis
merci valérie bénaïm qui a donné sa cave
n'est sa pierre à l'édifice oui madame
oui ça va pas vous donner de réponse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour vraiment aussi des tableaux j'ai
retrouvé mes fiches vous parlez de
l'audience
autant vous dire que c'était le j'aimais
beaucoup les missions une fois qu'on
l'avait en était sûr d'être intéressés
quand on le regarde même et que sur le
contenu de cette émission là c'était
difficile de faire venir les gens et les
audiences m'ont prouvé d'accord en fait
c'est pour ça que ma peau lui et tu
l'avais je sais pas mais vous l'avez vu
vous avez d analyser l'impact pour leur
dire et le redire à mon avis il est pas
mal pour marc aubry que je sais pas au
niveau des rythmes évidemment je veux
pas caricaturer isabelle n'est pas la
seule à galérer à prendre la parole et
chacun réagit à sa façon
celui qui m'a le plus étonné en fait
c'est maxime gainey on a mis de stéphane
bern
vous allez voir qu'on n'est pas content
et très démonstrative dans ses gestes
ambiance rap battle c'est une confession
assez assez forte regardez je me suis
penché sur le saisissant qui sans cet
été
et c'est bien tu adores c'est tout pour
moi c'était van rompuy c'est benoît qui
présentait à bahia
le mec était vraiment vénère parce qu'il
n'a pas l'air comme ça mais il a son
petit caractère gérard majax non mais je
m'en suis rendu compte pendant le prime
de la vérité est ce que vous vous
souvenez cette magnifique édition ou des
téléspectateurs était venue dire ce
qu'ils pensaient des chroniqueurs ouais
enfin sur tout le mal qu'ils pensaient
parce que je sais pas comment vous avez
fait votre casting dans les vérités vous
avez trouvé personne qui aimait
quelqu'un dans l'équipe donc cette
petite séquence de reproches publics ça
beaucoup plus un maximum ouais enfin
quand ça concernait pas après ça a un
peu dérapé
on a un bad boy dans l'équipe cyril
[Musique]
il dégage à côté légèrement méprisant
part aux gants je pense qu'au tour la
table il n'y a que des professionnels
des médias
tu ne te sens pas de trop
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maxime guinea moi je peux pas de berry
qui dénigrent un chroniqueur en direct
maxime maxime vous savez qui ce soir ont
dit toute la vérité way
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous traînons une prégnance des choses
qui nous est commun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour imposer toutes les questions que
vous voudrez dans un instant il ya el
mout également claqué notre détecteur de
mensonges humain
il alors déclaré
[Applaudissements]
et découvert envoie son cv il n'a pas
peur
connais tu te rates de dentelle et bien
qu'ils veulent moi il me dit j'ai adoré
ça dans ses bottes style de mec bas en
tout cas intellectuellement oui ah oui
il était derrière et intellectuellement
brillantissime j'ai adoré l moutier très
sympa ah ben oui qui nous hisse à fabas
et simplement il a moins aimé
hellmuth au nom est très sympa on va
enchaîner parce que non mais il trouva
d'assoli heureusement il ya syrie pour
tenir la baraque
cyril lui a jamais de relâche est
toujours au taquet comme la semaine
dernière avec la venue de francis
lalanne a c'est un cadeau de la vie ça
c'est vu que s'il assure recevoir pau au
contraire de jean michel maire regardez
la différence entre les compliments de
l'un et le remarque de l'autre ça fait
un an qu'il n'avait pas fait de
d'émissions de télé je me disais tout à
l'heure et que ton cheveux ne vieillit
pas non ma barbe
oui et c'est pour ça que la race oui
maman cheveux longs cheveux
et je vais acheter une chanson
magnifique je m'étais un peu éloigné de
l'analyse média et ton peuple tu crois
vraiment que c'est une question qu'on
pose un poète ci peut pas suivre tant de
temps à dix alors léo ferré par exemple
en tout cas celui qui avait la meilleure
place dans l'émission c'est boudeur
bouder je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
faisaient remarquer mais pendant deux
heures francis la garder dans ses bras
une peluche à la fête foraine s'est fait
remarquer il était au bout de sa vie
et
prends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les golds amer et profitez bien aussi
parce que des médias eurent cadeau de le
cas de francis vous savez cyril aime
bien se démarquer la concurrence alors
qu'en france issue a dit qu'il lui avait
amené en exclu le clip de son titre en
liga si l'animateur l'espace la série
nous mais parfois qui découvre ses
jouets à noël
un très beau moment d'émotion à bata
avec des artistes groenlandais et là
c'est le sétois la kia qui a les yeux
les premières images n'en pipe
oui bah oui ben normal tabasser des
premières du premier tu passes ça c'est
le premier à passer le clip de monde
cette chanson qui s'appelle chorale et
regarde alors t'en fous complet faire
plaisir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dunga fait à montélimar non si les
nougats de montélimar ont été obligés
bon allez on passe au top c'est dans
cette compilation des petits moments qui
ne peuvent se passer dans ces pme
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va tous écouté la solitudine même sa
voile tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi on m'a demandé
face à une jeune femme pour ses 40 ans
elle voulait mois en cadeau en fait
j'étais en haut de l'escalier c'est tout
et est donc ce arrivé et j'ai descendu
l'escalier mais vous y êtes allé pas
s'il y avait un peu hein
elle vient il put the swing pour janvier
sera vidé à la manger une banane
techno
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelques arrêts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok ok club pro tu prends ce sac tu vas
la tête que tu mets le sacre sur la
dépouille
vrai la bonne équipe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans un enclos des antilopes et elle a
été tout est centré sur le son la grille
qui entourait le champ où elle était et
on te prenais pas pourquoi
et en fait on s'est rendu compte que
quand elle avait moins à manger verne
elles se sont mis à bouffer les feuilles
des arbres et que les arbres qu'on se
venger en produits à haute dose du
poison du talent et que les antilopes
gardiens ont sauté c'est 100 foot en
paraît sur les enclos en australie
pourquoi c'est un thriller s'étaient
même si tu me survit d'être plus fort
touchant
je sais et merci à francis lalanne pour
le fabuleux hommage qu'il a fait 1 et
d'ailleurs vous pouvez le retrouver sur
sa page facebook je crois que francis
alors la semaine dernière étonnamment
nous avons également reçu quelqu'un venu
nous parler de johnny hallyday oui parce
que tous les jours il ya un truc qui
sort
dallas le monsieur était venu nous
raconter qu'il ya une quarantaine
d'années johnny avait essayé
d'assassiner quelqu'un avec une
bouteille de ketchup normal qui a qui
n'a jamais essayé
donc l'histoire a vite été passionnante
les bizarrement à un moment cyril a
décroché en fait au moment précis où
l'invité à parler de casser voir allez
voir c'est très net au début cyril a pas
l'air passionnés mais il s'accroche et
aux boucles au moca sets qu'a priori il
connaissait pas dans cet emploi il a
décroché
je pense que personne n'a compris
pourquoi il s'est mis à ricaner alors
j'ai essayé de rentrer dans son cerveau
je connais depuis vingt ans
sous le siège conducteur une cassette
avec de l'argent liquide cette époque-là
de jeunes y recevait parfois ses cachets
en argent liquide d'accord la cassette
elle a disparu et pour johnny il était
la maladie dans c'était une cassette
oui car cet ex d'argent liquide oui ça
m'agace est malade c'est bon on est
d'accord oui et donc oui et donc johnny
a toujours pensé que c'était mugnier qui
avait - qui ai l'argent
[Musique]
la cassette
elle a disparu et pour johnny il était
la maladie dans c'était une cassette
ballet mécanique
ak c'est johnny a toujours pensé que
c'était mugnier qui avait moins que
l'argent des coûts ce genre est ce que
ça voudrait que je parle un petit peu d
histoire de coeur de kelly ah bah alors
est-ce que calista très plaisir alors
mis à l'andi elle a un nouveau
prétendant
non avant et un après celui là on
l'avait pas vu venir harding et bernard
montiel
non non vous sérieux plus avec ça
ginette vous allez voir vous pose ça là
car c'est important poussé au courant
mais c'est une histoire en cours à warcq
in progress dans les magazines people
for
[Musique]
et c'est à peine un mois
kerry j'aimerais qu'en deuxième
mais pour être ce qu'albert etc
[Musique]
j'arrivais
et
france
frd
[Musique]
promène mon chien et communiqué
[Applaudissements]
magnifique séjour elle résiste alors
qu'il en crève d'envié
je sens très vite chez les femmes c'est
ouais bah il a fait ou fils à la truffe
c'est un peu plus doux mais quand même
ou pas
c'est ce que vous dites toujours bien
sûr christian des provinces et on
commence par benjamin 30 alors benjamin
30 c'est un service d'animateurs chez
vous en moins de 30 minutes vendredi et
la benjamin avait été appelé en urgence
pour remplacer au dernier moment si elle
n'a pas les grands succès d'ailleurs
puisqu'ils avaient dépassé millions sur
le seul souci c'est qu'en début
d'émission et s'était un peu emballé en
demandant au chroniqueur anonyme s'ils
étaient contents de le voir
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors eux j'espère que n'être pas trop
déçu sahara et et guillaume ii de me
voir à la passe de cyril on va faire
avec
[Applaudissements]
j'ai percé une carafe d'eau sur la tête
de mon rival où j'ai mis un gps dans le
téléphone de mon ex ah ça c'est dur de
mettre à bas tout est assez les plains
pas c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai fleurs
des papillons des corps médical et les
corps à corps
[Musique]
m
gemalto merci à toi je vais je voulais
faire un qui peuvent s'effacer derrière
mon petit écran c'est juste de dire à
thé playboy mettant pas en quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben ali
b
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]